Experion marketing services conducted a
rolling survey to determine whether
there any patterns between politics and
food on a rolling surveys where you got
gather information over a long period of
time and there are some interesting
findings which we've got a bunch of the
first one is conservative versus liberal
food chain so this is where
conservatives like to eat conservatives
love Oh Charlies Cracker Barrel that one
doesn't surprise me they like Hometown
Buffet
what is that next one Papa Papa Papa
Murphy's Longhorns steakhouse okay so
they seem these are meaty kind of things
hearty hearty meals where the Liberals
eating California Pizza Kitchen that
socialist you know macaroni grill Ruth's
Chris Steakhouse that one's kind of
pricey on the border that's Mexican PF
Changs everybody likes a little you know
chained Asian food next up a
conservative versus liberal fast food
chains so the Conservatives they're
digging crystal I actually don't know
what that is
so burger I don't know crystal burger
it's kind of any little burgers yeah
it's kind of like White Castle is kind
of the exact same thing same thing is
why okay they like crystal what else is
on there
what a burger that's mostly down south
I've seen in Texas uh Schlotzsky's Deli
which also I don't know that one where
am I I live in New York and LA Daily
Show
chick-fil-a that one doesn't surprise me
and they like Steak and Shake which is
big in the Midwest where the Liberals in
their fast-food a bond pun oh yes there
no there's snooty friends are all
hanging out in airports apparently a lot
of red leather bread Chipotle and you
know because per triple A's supposed to
be you know relatively healthy for you
as far as that goes
kadavo which is basically a Chipotle
knockoff bloopy I thought that was
interesting they like it more than
subway or what's the Quiznos and
Starbucks we of course know that the
Liberals are always hanging out in
Starbucks and one more on supermarket
chains chains this is where the
Conservatives are going they're going to
Randall's Weis markets Piggly Wiggly
Brookshire's and food town interestingly
that's so liberal Brookshire's
looks-wise Brookshire's Brookshire hey
can we go back to everybody say can we
go back
for Disick so I these first uh well
Piggly Wiggly I know but I don't think
I've been to any of these first four
food towns big on the East Coast yeah
these are the rest of these all do you
guys know are these these are all
Southern and Midwestern southern I've
only ever done Piggly Wiggly you've done
a very where the Liberals doing their
food shopping uh enough these liberals
go to Whole Foods whole paycheck foods
is they going Trader Joe's that's where
I do most of my shopping Fred Meyer Acme
and Safeway so there are some
interesting I think we can glean some
interesting stuff out of this do you
think you can get more information about
what people believe politically by this
kind of stuff than by polling them on
actual politics I think there might be
something to that
liberals obviously are much healthier is
that going back to the previous segment
yeah
liberals sorta want healthier stuff yeah
more vegetarians yeah yeah I do I mean I
think that if you were some sort of
advertising your consumer marketing
company and you wanted to be sneaky
about the way that you reach your
consumer yes you could go this route but
I don't think you're gonna glean more
information about somebody's political
views than asking them point blank what
are your political views I don't think
that there's some ulterior like weird
now everybody who Shops at whole from
exactly everybody I mean the truth is I
think that this is a [ __ ] study like
Point Blank this is a [ __ ] study I
remember once doing maybe it was the
Young Turks maybe it was the point I
remember I had a role of being on the
show with us and talking about maybe it
was even the common room and talking
about a similar study that was like I
can tell your political persuasion based
on the alcohol that you drink and it's
like know what you can tell is where I
live in the country and the truth is
there's a high correlation between this
type of food consumption and regional
differences and there's also a high
correlation between those regional
differences and political affiliation
and now those things are being conflated
carrot this is a hundred percent why I
bring because I'm not always sold on
these studies but I think that very
interesting that they get out there so
if someone can debunk them a little bit
I'm not there okay there's also a high
correlation between people that we're
Wranglers and people that we're I don't
know J Brand Jeans and their political
persuasion it's because of where you
live J Brand that's gonna be California
we're in New York it's gonna be a higher
scale client who shops at you know
Nordstrom or sex with Avenue and
Wrangler jeans like I'm from Texas I
know this this is going to be something
that people in the South are going to be
more likely to wear it's more of a
fashion statement that you see in the
south and so it's going to be more
likely that those people are
conservative and they're probably going
to drinks a whiskey instead of wine do
you think that that's possible
yeah or whiskey instead of vodka for
example so I think these are really just
regional differences in people because
that's where I think some of these some
of these restaurants so take advantage
of those regional differences and are
there on purpose because I know in the
South they're cracker barrels everywhere
really and I have friends who refuse to
go to them because when you walk in it's
like there's Jesus music playing there's
hats it's a John 3:16 on on all these
Bibles out and they just feel
uncomfortable so they won't go into
Cracker Barrell gravy biscuits they make
a hell of a potato really hard to do
with this conversation that we have a
lot of times about voting with your
dollar which I think starts to you know
the big chick-fil-a debate with I mean
maybe I'm just a sucker and I grew up in
Texas and I really like chick-fil-a I
apologize I'm not homophobic you know
that you know but I like homophobic
chicken because it tastes really good
and so here's here's part of the issue I
think is that it's the deck is stacked
against a lot of consumers in this
country and if we chase the money
ultimately we're going to get to
something we don't like ultimately we're
going to get to something that we are
polarized about and that we're
politically against and I get it if
you're somebody who can take the time to
do your due diligence and do all of your
research and figure out where you want
to shop based on your political
affiliations that's great and more power
to you but I don't like it when people
get high and mighty about telling other
people that they should do that to you
because like there's not enough [ __ ]
time in the day to research every single
thing I spend my money on yeah it gets
confusing I mean you know left to right
like Dolce & Gabbana are going to prison
right now for tax evasion in Italy and
like if you're against that you know
it's it goes from the top to the to the
bottom it goes from high to low it's
legislating the dark tomorrow
hello and pretty nice hey never shop
anywhere if you don't get gas at BP
exactly and somebody's making it's like
is it any better to get gas at Exxon no
and somebody's making a decision if
you're shopping at a multinational
conglomerate probably that they're
making money on the backs of other
people and this is a big difficulty in
capitalist society yes you can I
generally opt to eat at in and out over
these other choices because a it's
healthier right and B I do appreciate
their corporate values a little bit more
and I'd much rather go to a mom-and-pop
then go to a big chain but there are
times when I'm stuck I still have to put
gas in my car
the old lady we live in we all make
different choices and interesting the BP
thing you know the oil spill obviously
whichever which they were completely at
fault for most people were boycotting
their gas stations which are franchised
so you weren't even hurting the the
corporation the conglomerate you were
hurting the individual franchisees which
had nothing to do with any of the safety
thing at chick-fil-a
is it's a giant laser franchise and so
you see like the chick-fil-a
here in West Hollywood is not a
homophobic chick-fil-a at all people are
boycotting and they're like we're [ __ ]
with olliewood like look at everybody
who works here like we don't care and
that's a problem you know it's that we
don't know all of the ins and outs a lot
of these deals are done kind of in the
dark and they're shadowy and that the
records aren't available to the consumer
and taking political action via your
food choices I think is a good idea but
I also don't think it's always a
reasonable idea alright people there you
go we don't know everything about what's
in our food and who's selling us our
food we're doing the best we can
you